This episode of Dnews is brought to you by
BASF.
Does your garbage can runneth over?
Consider composting!
--
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and if you
find yourself with more garbage than you know
what to do with, it might be time to consider
composting.
I live in San Francisco, which is currently
the greenest city in the United States.
A while back, the city announced a goal to
achieve zero waste by the year 2020.
And by waste, they're referring to landfill
waste.
So composting is crucial here.
Every resident gets a free compost bin - but
for people outside of San Francisco, it's
not quite as easy.
Some cities charge you for bins, others don't
even offer them - which sucks.
But, that's okay - because it's super easy
to do yourself - and it's great for the environment.
So what is compost?
In a nutshell, it's a collection of organic
waste - aka food and plants - that decomposes
over several months, and eventually turns
into "humus" - which is an extremely nutrient-rich
soil.
What's special about it, is that in addition
to eliminating unnecessary landfill waste
- the soil it produces can also be used as
an organic fertilizer for your home garden.
So all composting requires three basic ingredients.
You need water, and you need an equal amount
of browns and greens.
Browns: tree matter - dead leaves, branches,
twigs, sawdust
Greens: typically wet - grass clippings, vegetable
waste, fruit scraps, coffee grounds, etc
You don't wanna put any meat, dairy, or bread
items in your compost, because those will
rot and attract pests.
Also, it's recommended you do this outdoors.
If you live in an apartment, or don't have
a backyard- you CAN do it indoors, but it's
a little bit trickier, and it needs more maintenance.
So for the purposes of this video, I will
show you how to do it outside.
First things first - you wanna select a container
for your compost, and place it in a grassy,
relatively shaded part of your yard.
If you're handy you can build a container
yourself - or you can buy one from any home
& garden store - just make sure it's the right
size.
You want it to fit everything you have, but
not be too big - and you want your compost
heap to be touching the ground, so make sure
whatever container you use doesn't have a
bottom on it.
You'll wanna start by laying a few inches
of twigs or straw at the bottom, to help aerate
the pile.
And then, you can start adding waste.
The biggest rule to remember when composting,
is that you want an equal balance of nitrogen,
carbon, water, and air.
Nitrogen is found in those greens I listed
earlier, and Carbon is found in the browns.
So equal amounts green and brown.
You'll wanna chop up any big chunks of material
before putting them in - and it's also important
to avoid any highly processed foods, since
those'll take longer to break down.
But generally speaking, as long as you maintain
that balance of materials, the compost will
naturally begin to attract all of those organisms
that eventually break it down.
Once you've set everything up and added your
waste, it's pretty hands off from there.
If you're gonna be adding new scraps regularly,
I suggest burying them in the center of the
pile.
That will naturally aerate all of it, which
is something you wanna be doing every week
anyway.
If you notice your pile is getting too dry,
just water it a bit.
And if it's super hot or rainy outside - it
might also help to cover it with something,
to maintain the right balance of moisture.
After a few months, your compost should be
ready to use.
You'll know when it turns a nice dark brown
color, develops an earthy smell, and is warm
to the touch - which is a product of the microbes
living inside.
And at this point, you can go ahead and mix
the compost soil into your garden.
Just remember this should be used as an additive
and not as the sole source of soil in your
garden.
That could turn out very poorly.
If you know of any other ways to "go green"
on the cheap, hit us up on
Twitter at @Dnews and let us know.
Otherwise, happy composting!